let's make way for Marcellus Wiley he
worked at the mothership for your attend
you she's coming in clean here coming in
hot
he transitioned to Fox is that ago is
that what it's called you transitioned
to Fox yeah they try to highbrow right
sometimes you know yeah got up early he
co-hosts the show speak for yourself
and now sharing his unique story he's
got a new book never shut up the life
and opinions and unexpected adventures
of an NFL outlier and of course
Columbia's finest Marcellus Wiley
oh good see I've never heard that at the
frat party so that was Columbia's finest
okay but you come out of Compton and you
end up at Columbia yeah what was the
other choice Oh big football factories a
lot of the typical recruiting I was
doing well on the football field in high
school so UCLA was a high on the list
Cal Berkeley was a dream school but the
coach actually left with the Arizona
State so that kind of changed my
aspirations but you say to the boys in
the in the hood here income yeah and
they go hey wait where you gonna go play
yeah when I said Columbia they're like
dude that kind of contrasts man all the
elders the counselors the teachers their
eyebrows raised when I said Columbia and
all of my friends all my peers were like
dude I don't know what the hell you're
doing and you're not gonna make it to
the NFL so I just had to deal with that
dichotomy made the long game choice even
though there were some sacrifices made
but you didn't go to a good football
team you noticed huh our history I mean
not even a good Ivy League team yeah
it's weird I didn't know the reputation
I didn't know what I was really walking
into the 44 game losing streak worst
reputation in college football but I
thought that was a challenge once I
heard the story cuz I never felt the
story so I had to internalize it but
once I heard it I was like that's
interesting and my coach told me
something that has stuck with me since
he said do you want to go somewhere and
carry the torch or go somewhere and
light the torch and I knew I could have
impact on a program like Columbia and
we beat a big fish in a little pond
let's talk about Le'Veon Bell you know
everybody's got an opinion here you
played if you were a Steeler offensive
lineman I would have shut it up I would
have never said a word but I'm gonna let
that go okay yeah you don't talk about
someone else's money it's just a cold of
the locker room or the code of any
business sector I've been in I just made
that transition and when you make the
transition my cohost weren't talking
about what my next opportunities were we
were doing our job in that moment
something that distillers now are forced
to live through is let's focus on who's
here
I don't understand why they didn't do
that a month or two ago but let's say
your contract is up at Fox at the end of
the football season and you say to Jason
Whitlock mmm I'm gonna sit out the rest
of the season I want to rest my vocal
cords here how is that gonna go over
with the folks at Fox and Jason Whitlock
your co-host that you're gonna you got
to sit out because I don't want to
strain my voice before I got to get my
new contract yeah well you hit me we
rehearse I've had vocal cord surgery
actually two years ago so not not
exactly apples to apples but look we all
know that candidly we have conversations
that we don't air out to the public free
agency and NFL yeah I knew some teams
that were interested in me was it
against the the ethics of the league was
it against the guidelines was I supposed
to have that report it absolutely not
but things happen at 9:30 when your
agents at the combine before free agency
the same thing with Jason Whitlock he
will have to understand I'm gonna have
one level of conversation with you which
is going to be explicit and candid and
then there's another level which we're
gonna promote and project to the public
which is gonna be the safe PC way I
don't understand it just happens every
day in the NFL we know stuff that is
occurring that we can't air out but this
was a situation they did should we treat
runningbacks differently mmm there
she'll fly naturally contract wise it's
a finite shelf-life I play running back
my entire life until I get to the NFL
and they're like deal you're to 18
there's no way
but at Columbia beating up on Dartmouth
like we did yes we did
not really not much not much I'm gonna
tell you the Dartmouth stories they
destroyed us every single years but I
got mine you look at it the running back
position has just it's almost devolved
in terms of how valuable it is their
shelf life is short I'll play with some
great running backs Thurman Thomas
LaDainian Tomlinson and they have to get
it while the getting is good and I
respect those guys for that and I
respect Le'Veon Bell for what he's doing
it's a hell of a gamble I mean whoever
is this this financial advisor you gave
up five years 70 you gave up 14 and a
half we have to add that to whatever you
get going forward let's see if a team is
that thirsty and she better than Todd
Gurley
no I think that he's more unconventional
his jogging to wait for opportunities
and then exploit them it's something
that we haven't seen you that level of
patience and waiting for the hose to to
open Todd Gurley is a workhorse who has
some of that but he also has a
horsepower that I don't think Le'Veon
Bell has I mean you look at James Conner
and what he's doing right now
no comparison to Le'Veon bill but by the
numbers just because he has a different
level of horsepower he's actually
exploiting defenses in that system the
fact that the Chiefs in the Rams have
relocated to Los Angeles it feels like
we're getting we're getting closer to
either being in London or Mexico City
yes okay if I said in the next five
years will there be an NFL team based
outside of the United States
absolutely I think quietly there's some
teams raising their hand saying it that
we want to be out there where you want
to say maybe a Jacksonville I hate to do
this to my bills mafia but even Buffalo
may be in consideration they were
talking about Toronto when I was a
Buffalo Bill now I was in the late 90s
they have to keep pace with the NBA and
it's globalization of its game but you
would you want to live in Mexico City
would you want to live in London if you
were a player I would I think about it
like you're in your early 20s you have
millions of dollars you're going to see
the world
and show the world your talents I know a
lot of guys Ivy Leaguers who went
overseas and a fill Europe they love
their experience especially in your 20s
when you're trying to figure things out
early stages adulthood you get to see
more than just a typical absolutely I
know that logistics and a travel may be
an issue but the exposure sounds like
it's worth it to me he's Marcellus Wiley
Fox Sports host former defensive end and
his show is speak for yourself he's got
a book never shut up the life opinions
and unexpected adventures of an NFL
outlier do you still have a crab beef
with anybody from when you play beef
like is there carryover if you see
somebody it's like if something said or
like it could be go time no no you know
me I'm fun-loving man I was one of the
weird guys in the league I laughed
before every game like I'm a dirty - you
cut the entire different Broncos
offensive line Lincoln Kennedy wasn't
dirty but I thought it was unfair that
he played the position I had to see 60
70 times on Sundays his his arms his his
biceps were like hamstrings and it was
like he I was a man and he was a ma'am
oh what the hell are you doing here and
this is the funniest part about football
we only focus in on the injuries and oh
my god he's out there he got laid out
whatever it may be
it's the second and six and they get two
yards and we get up in lineup back in
the huddle in his third and four no one
knows that he just dislocated my finger
no one knows that he just punched me so
hard that I actually thought about
Vontae Davis and said this is my moment
right here between the huddle I could
get out of here but the cameras are on I
mean there's so many moments in football
because for you to exercise a wheel to
be greater and bigger than yourself
there's a lot of moments you're like are
you gonna do it there's a lot of moments
of truth where if I don't do this I
could tap out right now and football
will challenge you to never tap out and
I think that's the beauty of it but
people never talk about the conversation
you have with yourself
about am I going to run through that
next wall what's the best story of all
your broken fingers you have a good
I can tell you this one it's funny
because Bill Parcells I'm in Dallas oh
my god yeah
so I be careful when you hold that one
up I'm playing Chicago and Lyman is
running left
I see the cutback I'm trying to go right
back dis just tendons flying everywhere
this is just turns into this flamingo
here right and I just like a yoga pose
and in my mind I'm like I know fingers
are laughed at in NFL in terms of injury
where's it on the pecking order so I
knew I was going to still play but the
way the disregard for my pain by Bill
Parcells and others it caught me off
guard so all they did was give me a
bridge tape they call it that he's like
oh that's he'll be all right
turn away yanked him and pulled it
things started to crack again and then
from there they taped it to the next one
poor healthy finger over here say well
I'm dealing with him so they're together
and then I go out there like this and
the rest of the game I didn't touch the
guy with my left hand and then obviously
I didn't have a great year in Dallas and
this is part of it this is the reason it
can't be fixed you know they say you can
have finger surgery and finger rehab
that just doesn't sound fun and that
sounds like the most manly thing I could
do
plus I think it would get jammed up and
messed up and I don't think it would
ever get back to normal it was the
craziest player you ever played against
Rodney Harrison comes to mind like you
know they always say you got to go to
deco to whistle you know the one where
Rodney it wasn't just the echo of the
whistle Rodney was so into the zone and
I loved him for that because that was
another aspirational place another
another wall to run through like can i
play with that level of intensity
I love Rodney for that still one of my
best friends from the game he was psycho
you know what else was psycho John
Henderson from Jacksonville used to get
slapped every game before by the
training staff that was
interesting wait oh you don't know these
stories oh my god this guy 673 30 and he
would get so psyched up that he he
needed someone to slap him and I'm not
talking about like a nice little PC
camera slap I'm talking about full-on
you talked about my mama and you date my
sister Wow and they would hit him so
hard and he was a crispy woman he used
to walk around with smelling sauce in
his nostrils one in each nostril and
walk around he'd leave him in he'll
leave him in and walking around pregame
and no one talked to him no one got in
his way and no one wanted to deal with
her because Chris Spielman was next
level yeah he was a little crazy too oh
yeah big-time big-time he dislocated his
shoulder one time and popped it back in
and was like let's keep playing next
level stuff leashed athletic quarterback
you ever played against Tom Brady Brady
drew bledsoe all the Patriots I guess
Dan Marino at the end wasn't proven well
you wasn't fast to begin with yeah that
wasn't pretty but um I came in when
there were the seven step drop sit back
there statue hey let me survey the field
and you could catch a lot of guys like
that they've changed it now the
specialty training these one-on-one
coaches these gurus no matter what your
athletic base is you can improve in the
pocket you can maneuver in the pocket
even Brady has gotten much better in the
pocket step here step there so is
usually the statues of yesterday where
the order were to works did you ever
like that moment that a defensive player
right before you hit a quarterback like
in the back like that what is that
moment like that good feels like it's
it's only a split second but it feels
like you can almost see it in slow
motion if you're the one who's gonna hit
this quarterback he doesn't know you're
coming
exactly it is in slow motion because the
first thing you think is I better not
miss this opportunity then you're
thinking I'm about to send a message oh
my god like
you know hide your wife hide the kids
this is gonna hurt and then there's a
moment where you're trying not to blink
because you just don't want to lose
sight of it and then I think my favorite
one that I could still visualize is
Bruce Smith was on the right edge and he
was coming around and I see this from
the video after the fact but he's coming
around and he's going on low on Peyton
Manning but I'm coming up high six six
Peyton Manning and I'm like I'm about to
get him oh I'm about to get him but
Bruce gets there slightly before me and
he knocks Peyton down a peg
so I'm teeing off on like shoulder level
which now turns into head level which
turns it to the neck which turns into a
tenth of the night behind we started to
play men in looking like oh my god in
four surgeries later I'm like was this
the domino effect was this to started at
but there are moments like that where
you just don't want to let slip through
your fingers if you were starting your
team ne pense rusher ah Koerner Alton Oh
current all-time oh now you helping me
Bruce Smith why cuz Bruce could play
over the nose three play and he has the
most sacks in history he had this
unbelievable ability to run sideways as
fast as you could run forward what do I
mean when when a guard tackle fans on
you and you got that little space you
got to get skinny to get in there not
only could he get skinny and turn his
hips but he can move up feel sideways
faster than we could sometimes running
straight ahead that in his hand I was
the best ever seen I may be biased cuz I
got to see it every day in practice
every day in the games but by far I've
never seen a technician like that
how about current Blair mmm current
player Aaron Donald's hand combat is
next level Joey Bosa when new and
healthy is is a motor that I desired you
look at Khalil Mac that's just our
athletic base that has just been
accented to a next level like he's so
powerful so strong so quick so fair
give me a combo of Voltron of those guys
I take it if I gave you a healthy JJ
Watt or Erin Donald who now you're
cooking now you cook it uh god JJ JJ
Watt by just pure leverage and levers
whenever you have a guy with that that
those extremities like he can just seems
like stand up straight and still touch
the ground that punch you can get he's
just a lot to deal with it's funny you
say when healthy the comparisons were
early for him he had tremendous season
20-plus he is he a Hall of Famer right
now I tell you one one Hall of Famer
told me as I'm on air giving JJ Watt all
the love and credit he says call me in
ten years when he does the same thing
because you have to be available you
have to be healthy you have to be
consistent and I think that's what's
undermining right now but for me yes do
you want to hit somebody before you
leave
holy Fiedler was a beast
yeah no Jay Fiedler wunderbar you didn't
go to any games did you Dan I did I
actually did a story on Colombia when
they had that losing streak oh I was at
CNN in the mid 80s and I went to
Colombia one of the first dates I had
with my wife and we went I took her to
Colombia and she sat in the stands with
like nine other people watched and we
watched Colombia Lou because I was going
to do the story on the losing streak and
I'm thinking and I you know I got a
story either way if you win you broke
the streak but no you guys you guys
lived up the reputation they retire your
jersey at Columbia no I know about that
because some of our alums Bob Kraft is
an alum you got to respect that
there's a Sid look man Lou Gehrig like I
get it like there are some names out
there that I have not trumped but uh but
football wise I mean it's not a long
list of great players at Columbia no
Marty Dahmer is was a first-round former
charger yeah George stark one of the
yeah it'd be nice I think I need to
donate a little more maybe I I'll leave
you with this I remember asking I was it
IceCube when I I said how would it go if
I went into Compton and he goes
brother's got cable you said you'll be
fine you know this is a long time ago I
said how would I what I do in Compton
got cable they watch SportsCenter okay
[Music]
the show is speak for yourself on Fox
he's transitioned to Fox Sports and his
book has never shut up the life opinions
and unexpected adventures of an NFL
outlier he's dad dude Marcellus Wiley
great to see again Marcellus thank you
for coming for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]